deena they've given us this tremendous
knowledge right they say used to
moivre's theorem okay now just have a
look at this line first okay have a look
at the right-hand side do you see do you
see that even without having been told
news Dubois vers theorem there's a big
fat clue in fact there are two big that
codes that tell you that should sort of
signal de moivre's theorem based on this
right hand side what are the two clues
look at him yeah yep
very good yeah yeah yeah okay good the
giveaways right
we know awkward for de Moura sir is if
you have a number like this and you
raise it to the power n then you're
gonna raise the modulus to that power
and you're going to multiply the
arguments by that house okay so we can
that's right hands say so much someone
will look up your work and say hey man
you spent that with two N's and I'm like
no no that's so this has clues about
that tell us but when you look at this
left hand side what's the problem it's
in rectangular form okay so I first like
you remember I said to you okay you've
got to think about how you go through
this the first thing you all basically
have to do is put these into polar form
so you can work with it so let's do that
okay um consider let's have a look at
one okay one plus I where is it get an
image in your mind the 1 means go to the
right a unit the eye means go up okay so
you've got that that little sort of
triangle and you're in your head right I
want to convert this into polar form so
if I've got to the right up there we go
what's the matos this is 102 a beauty
so there's the modulus what's the
argument oh yeah it's just pie on four
oh right of course it's final four okay
good so I hit in the right direction so
let's write that down
okay now that's what what was I so I
converted successfully the reason I
converted it is so I can use de moivre's
owner right so let's do that I'm gonna
raise this to the nth power which means
what happens to the modules also gets
raised to the N power okay this is
actually not you remember I say its
intimidating but oh you don't few steps
and you clearly ahead in the right
direction
he's the modulus raised to the nth power
and then here is the argument and it
gets multiplied by M okay yeah you're
with me yep in exactly the same way also
one - I okay think about where that is
you still went one unit to the right and
then you go one unit down right so
you've got the same triangle but so one
one same modulus but what's the argument
it's negative Pilon forward yeah okay so
let's let's go through this this is
still row tune this is cos of negative
pi on four plus I sine of negative PI on
fault yep
you can go ahead you can apply tomorrow
soon to it just like before I should
said that by the way by de moivre's do
I'm gonna raise this to the nth power do
you see this is not actually that bad at
all right it's not that bad at all
you've got here minus M high on for
another minus n PI on 4 ok so now tell
me what to do
come on you what all the pieces there ok
so there's a couple of different things
and I think I sorta have to do both of
them I'm clearly gonna add these things
right clearly gonna add them right so I
can say therefore the left-hand side of
this result that was being given to me
it's gonna be this Plus this you see
that so I'm gonna have this one at the
front I just want to do this straight
substitution this one after it now
look after you've both - as soon as you
write this have a look at where you're
headed
have a look at the result you're headed
towards ok what's going to happen what
has to happen
yeah few things out that but we're
number 1 this routes you to the end it
happens to X will it it better happen
twice so I can factor it out less than
that then what's the next thing that has
to happen
what's the glaring obvious seaman's in
this line but not in those lines there's
no science do you notice your no signs
of course there are no science because
what's gonna happen to this guy sine is
an odd function right so I sine of
negative in Pilon 4 is the same as minus
I sine in platform right so let's go
ahead and we'll get that out of it and
pi
for my sign and plan for now that's not
the only thing that we use symmetry of
functions to take advantage of this is a
minus M plan for this is a regular and
powerful so for what reason can switch
this it's an even functions very good
are you saying to get it like we've used
this many times this is why we go on
about Auden even functions earlier
people like who cares about these things
like who cares if it's about this
symmetry like why for the class of later
because you can use it right they say
it's very usable so here we go I've got
it cause anyone for plus minus rather
I'm just hiring because of time but you
should write here you know because like
the reason why I can do this is because
of the symmetry of those functions and
then you can see what happens right
cancel cancel cos n PI over 4 plus cos n
pi and 4 is 2 cos n PI over 4 are you
happy I'm not even gonna write that line
because it's just that line